I just saw this article in the Atlantic
is published this week written by Annie
Lowry and it has the title canceled
billionaires and it's a call it's well
it's calling to cancel billionaires get
rid of billionaires is the exact phrase
used in the article I'm not sure if
we're talking about get rid of rich
people like French Revolution style or
get rid of them just by stealing their
money or maybe a little bit of both but
the point is there shouldn't be any
billionaires that's that's the point
bill that billionaires are a policy
failure that's the that were the way the
left often puts it these days I just
have one question when I read this kind
of stuff I'm taking any Lowry for
example do you think that if I offered
her a billion dollars she would turn it
down if if she had a long-lost rich
uncle who died and was going to bequeath
a million dollar a billion dollars to or
even a million do you think she'd turn
it down all of these people who whine
about the rich would any of them turn
down a billion dollars or a million
dollars or any money I'm guessing
probably zero point zero percent of them
would why well because the main thing
they hate about rich people is that they
personally are not one so every time you
hear someone going on about the rich
realize that what they're really saying
with what you have you could really
translate it what they're really saying
is I am upset that I am not rich that's
my issue it is a the whining about the
rich is very thinly veiled envy it is
envy dressed up to look like moral
righteousness and that's really all it
is and we should always keep that in
mind all right
much to discuss this afternoon Planned
Parenthood has announced that it's going
to spend forty five million dollars
speaking of millions of dollars Planned
Parenthood is now this is going to spend
forty five million dollars to help the
Democrats win the election that's an
interesting plan for a tax funded
company so we're gonna talk about that
also Matt Lauer is the subject of a
brutal rape allegation
but I think there may be reason to
possibly be skeptical we'll discuss it
there's also a conspiracy theory
percolating right now around the story
of you know the police officer who was
convicted of murder for walking into
someone else's apartment and shooting
them claimed it was an intruder she
thought it was intruder she was in the
wrong apartment whatever well there's um
there's a conspiracy theory now around
that whole story and we're gonna take a
look at that also and more but first a
word from Harry's you know humans have
been shaving for thousands of years I
don't know if you knew that and the
secret to a great shave really hasn't
changed much that entire time the
ancient Greeks they shaved they didn't
have flex balls or heated handles or any
of that fancy stuff and you don't need
it either that's why
Harry's doesn't overcharge you to add
gimmicky features to their razors all
that stuff the bells and whistles they
don't bother with that they focus on
delivering what actually matters which
is sharp durable blades at a fair price
now I use Harry's myself and I love it
for the great prices the smooth shave
the way the blades stay very sharp
that's the main thing you don't need you
know you got these these things now or
it's like ten blades and the swivel and
it's heated and all this all you need
just needs to be sharp it's sharp you're
fine that's the main thing and yes I do
shave it is a stereotype and a myth that
bearded men don't shave I have to I have
to use razors otherwise I'd have I'd
have hair coming out of my eyeballs
right now if I didn't shave it all so
Harry's is a return to the essential
which is quality durable blades at a
fair price just two dollars per blade
that's it they've cut out the middleman
they and and what they're doing is
they're just bringing the blades right
to you listeners of my show can redeem
their Harry's trial set at harrys.com
slash matt walsh you'll get a weighted
economic handle for a firm blade you'll
get a five blade razor with a
lubricating strip and trimmer blend
trimmer blade you'll get rich lathering
shave gel with aloe to keep your skin
hydrated which is important part of this
and a travel blade a travel blade cover
that is to keep your razor dry and easy
to grab on the go all you have to do is
go to harrys.com slash matt walsh to
start shaving better today
all right reading now from the hill
Planned Parenthood's super PAC announced
a forty five million dollar electoral
campaign on Wednesday to defeat
President Trump and Republicans and key
Senate races the investment will fund a
quote large-scale grassroots
organization and canvass digital
television radio and mail programs
Kelly Robinson executive director of
Planned Parenthood votes in an interview
with the hill said the stakes are higher
than ever and we're going out more
powerfully than ever with the largest
investment we've ever made the campaign
will focus on Arizona Colorado Florida
Michigan Minnesota New Hampshire North
Carolina Pennsylvania Wisconsin those
states are must wins for Trump but
Republican senators are also keep
fighting to keep their seats in Arizona
Arizona Colorado North Carolina and
races that will determine which party
controls the Senate after 2020 the
campaign which could exceed 45 million
dollars will tell voters there is a
coordinated attack among Republicans and
state legislators and so on and so forth
Robinson said we know we're going to
have a critical role mobilizing those
those folks to win back the Senate and
expand the path to 270 to win back the
presidency win back the presidency
notice the the language used there
Planned Parenthood wants to win back the
presidency why because they know that
wow if you say well how was Planned
Parenthood going to win the presidency
well because they know that if the
Democrats have the presidency then they
have it because they own the Democrat
Party but this is very interesting 45
million dollars on an explicitly
political campaign 45 million dollars to
elect Democrats that's what they're
trying to do and they're open about it
right and that would be fine because I
think if companies want to do that they
can't except for the fact that this is a
tax funded organization they get five
hundred million dollars a year from the
taxpayers and now they want to turn
around and take that money that was
taken from the taxpayers and spend it to
advance a political agenda that will
specifically help Democrats now it's a
great
deal for Democrats you know as Planned
Parenthood is nothing more than really a
slush fund for them well a Democrat
slush fund that also kills babies which
the Democrats are fan of fans of also
that is killing babies they're obviously
big fans of that it's their favorite
thing in the world killing babies but so
but this is an arrangement is a great
deal if you can get it they again they
they take money from taxpayers give it
to Planned Parenthood and then Planned
Parenthood turns around and gives the
money back to them through campaign
contributions that attack ads against
their opponents and so on it is
essentially money laundering Planned
Parenthood is like the car wash in in
Breaking Bad money laundering operation
except instead of washing cars that
kills babies now let's remember all of
the hand wringing that goes on
whenever the possibility of defunding
Planned Parenthood is brought up in fact
here's a here's I found this online
here's a video that Planned Parenthood
put out a few months ago talking about
the the danger of defunding them and all
the bad things that will happen if we do
watch this Planned Parenthood provides
care for patients across the country no
matter their zip code their income their
race their immigration status their
sexual orientation or gender identity no
matter what in Washington some
politicians are trying to defund Planned
Parenthood
but what does that really mean millions
of people come to Planned Parenthood for
health care services like birth control
STD tests cancer screenings and sex
education
and Planned Parenthood proudly provides
safe and legal abortion a medical
procedure federal health programs won't
pay for except in extremely rare
circumstances the care that patients get
at Planned Parenthood prevents an
estimated five hundred seventy nine
thousand unintended pregnancies each
year and saves lives through early
detection of cancer actually we stopped
there for just one second because I I
just noticed this and let's let's freeze
frame right here because how
symbolically appropriate is this this is
great
notice how the women in this graphic
they have no eyes or they have no ears
no eyes no no they just have a mouth
that's all they have isn't that kind of
interesting because that really is how
Planned Parenthood wants women to be
when they come in that's how Planned
Parenthood sees women that's that is how
they want women to essentially act when
they come in they want women to be blind
kept in the dark not able to see clearly
don't look at the ultrasound don't look
at your other options don't look at the
literature that the planned pair the the
pro-life people out out front tried to
hand you on your way and don't look at
it yet stuff keep your eyes closed well
will lead you back at this in this back
room here and we'll kill you babe your
baby don't look at anything else they
want their women to be eyeless blind and
so that is some stunning symbolism in
that graphic anyway continue so when
politicians talk about defunding Planned
Parenthood they're not talking about
striking a line in a federal budget
they're talking about blocking millions
of women men and young people from
getting essential and life-saving care
here's what their plan would cost
Americans an estimated one in five women
in America have been to a Planned
Parenthood in their lifetime nearly half
of all Planned Parenthood patients are
people of color for many people Planned
Parenthood is the only place they can
get
care in their community in fact more
than half of Planned Parenthood health
centers are in rural or underserved
communities defunding Planned Parenthood
would be disastrous for our nation's
health and the people who would be hurt
most would be those already struggling
to get by blocking women from
life-saving care defunding would be
disastrous for women's health think of
all the poor women who will will not
have access to health care because of
this this is what they tell us that's
the argument that's what they say and
yet they've got 45 million bucks to
throw around on political campaigns so
they tell us if you stop giving us money
women will die and they also tell us hey
we've got 45 million dollars to go and
burn on campaign ads there seems to be a
contradiction here in fact it was it was
just last year there was a very small
sort of partial defunding of Planned
Parenthood that happened where the
company was deprived of about I think 50
million I think it was it was fifty
million dollars 50 million dollars of
tax money isn't going to Planned
Parenthood anymore
now they're still getting about five
hundred million dollars so that 50
million dollars is nothing as a drop in
the bucket but and they told us that
even taking that that 50 million away is
disastrous and it's gonna kill women and
they're not gonna be so you take away 50
million though there won't be able to
function without the 50 million yet they
have 50 million that they're gonna spend
on campaign ads so it's it would again
appear to be a contradiction and this is
this is the thing even if Planned
Parenthood didn't murder 300,000
children a year it would still be an
outrage to give them tax money
considering how politically active they
are now of course if they didn't murder
babies they wouldn't need to be
politically active because they you know
their their their political activism is
all about protecting their bottom line
and because they're worried that they'll
be stopped from killing babies and
making all the money they make off of
that but they didn't kill babies to
begin with and they wouldn't need to be
politically active but putting all that
aside it is it is
obviously corruption blatant naked
corruption for a tax funded institution
to donate to political causes and all
I'll say is this if you are ok with this
then I don't and it doesn't matter how
you feel about abortion if you're ok
with this a company that gets five
hundred million dollars a year in tax
money turning around and donating
millions to political campaigns if
you're fine with that
that I don't want to hear you whining
about the influence of money and
politics or corporate greed or corporate
corruption or anything else because this
is the number one example of all of that
of course we should note that
Republicans had a chance to cut off this
pipeline and to put an end to this
Democrat money-laundering operation they
had a chance to do it they could have
done it they for two years they had the
presidency and they had the house in the
Senate and they could have done it and
they did it because Republican Party is
filled of course with idiots and cowards
all right well moving on I hate to have
to call this out but you know the
hippies are at it again
out in the street protesting the climate
and as you know I love playing these
videos for you nothing better than
hippie videos as far as I'm concerned
but this one this one really upset me
watch this
all I'm gonna say is is is look if
you're gonna copy my morning workout
routine at least give me credit okay you
damned plagiarists that's all okay so
there's this um there's this book coming
out a book by Ronan Farrow the guy who
broke the Weinstein story and has broken
a bunch of the me2 stories and he's got
a book coming out and it contained
that's it's you know talks about that
story you know but it also contains a
new allegations including an explosive
one about Matt Lauer we know that Matt
Lauer got fired from NBC for four you
know it was never clear exactly what
what he did it was just sort of
inappropriate conduct and he was kind of
a creep and that sort of thing but the
book goes into details about what
exactly Matt Lauer actually did and that
includes rape the allegation is from
Brooke nevels a former employee of NBC
now she had an affair with Matt Lauer
which I guess we knew about that and
both her and Lauer admit that there was
a long-term months-long
relationship between two sexual
relationships but Neville says now in
the book that at the beginning of the
relationship I guess I believed this
there was their first sexual encounter
it was a violent rape she says that they
were at a hotel because they were
covering the Olympics and and she came
up to Lauer's hotel room she was invited
to Lauer's hotel room she came and
apparently Matt Lauer answered the door
to his underwear who's wearing boxers
and and she came in and and then she
says he forced himself on her and raped
her now it seems most people have taken
this allegation as people tend to do
these days they've taken this allegation
and the others in pharaoh's book as
gospel as fact unquestioned there you go
and maybe it is a fact I'm you know I'm
certainly no Matt Lauer fan I didn't
like the guy even before any of this
stuff I always thought he was a creep
always came off to me as creepy even
before any of this when he got caught up
in the enemy to thing I was not
surprised in the least I was very much
expecting that that's always been my
impression of him but that doesn't mean
he's a rapist of course he could be I
don't know maybe but I think there are
two giant red flags here that we should
point to we should point out that I
think a lot of people are overlooking
the first red flag and and this is a big
one doesn't mean in and of itself that
the allegation is false but when a rape
allegation is used to sell a book that
to me is reason for skepticism when just
in general in fact forget about rape
allegation any time an explosive detail
or rumor or gossip or anything like that
anytime there's a juicy juicy little
tidbit about you know damaging damning
about someone and it's it's put in a
book and it's used to promote the book
then that's that's a reason to be
skeptical it doesn't mean it's not true
it's just you have to ask yourself if
this actually happened is this the way
that we'd be hearing about it does it
make sense that this detail has been
sort of saved up to be used in a
promotional way to sell a book that you
have to ask yourself that now it so at
the very least this is a very cynical
thing in my mind the fact that Ronan
Farrow is using this if it did happen
using a rape just because this is gonna
sell a lot of books the book would have
been a best-seller anyway but now a lot
of people are gonna hear about this
because it's in the news and they're
gonna and it's it's impossible to
believe that that wasn't part of the
calculation and so at the very least we
have something cynical doesn't mean it's
not true but it's a reason to be
skeptical and in the second the second
red flag as far as I can tell is that is
that she admits that she continued the
relationship with Matt Lauer
after the alleged rape took place which
again maybe that's how it happened it's
why I can't say it didn't happen that
way but it does seem strange if you were
brutally raped by someone that you would
then continue in a sexual relationship
with them for months consensually maybe
I don't know seem strange so I think
there's reason for skepticism and this
shows again why the believe women slogan
is is flawed or a slogan like this the
National the National Women's Law Center
put out a tweet after the Lauer news
broke probably mainly in reference to it
and here's the tweet now first of all
this thing on Twitter where people
repeat a phrase over and over as if that
makes it more convincing now I'm not a
fan of that personally I don't think
anyone's gonna read a statement and go
hmm well I'm not really sure about that
and then see that it's been repeated
nine times and say okay well I mean if
they repeated it nine times
it must be correct but the point is that
listen to survivors as is being insisted
here is a bad motto it's a bad approach
because the whole point is we don't know
if somebody is a survivor just because
they say they are you know we we have to
look first at the evidence to determine
if someone is a survivor and then if it
seems like they are then yeah we listen
but that's the whole question what this
slogan really means to say what it
really seems to mean is assume all
accusers are survivors and then listen
to them or assume all women who call
themselves survivors are in fact
survivors and that is a very very bad
precedent a precedent that in fact
undermines our entire judicial system
our entire approach to criminal justice
is contradicted by destroyed by this
believe women nonsense this is one of
the the fundamental principles of our
judicial system is that no you don't
just
believed someone because they accuse
another person the fact that an
accusation is made is not in and of
itself conclusive evidence that the
accused thing actually happened
obviously so no we don't we don't we
don't believe women we don't believe men
we look at evidence and we believe
credible allegations that's what we
believe doesn't matter if it's a woman
making it or a man making it makes no
difference the fact that a woman is the
one making allegation that doesn't make
it more credible doesn't make it less
credible it's just it's an allegation
you have to look at it maybe there's
more evidence for this mantle our thing
I don't know but what we have now as far
as I can tell is an accusation in a book
used to sell a book and that's what we
have not enough to assume that it's true
okay I wanted to talk about this because
it's just it's a really good example of
how conspiracy theories develop and and
why conspiracy theories are almost
always BS so you remember the trial of
amber Geiger she was the the Dallas cop
who shot and killed a man in his
apartment says that she was confused
about she went to the wrong apartment
thought it was her apartment there was a
guy in there I thought it was an
intruder shot and killed him and and now
she's going to prison for ten years she
was convicted of murder which by the way
I totally agree that she needs to go to
prison for that
I thought the merton I'm a little
surprised that she was convicted on the
murder charge I thought it'd be more of
a manslaughter thing because I don't
think anyone who thinks that this was
premeditated like she went into because
she really just wanted to kill the guy I
think her story about how she was in the
wrong apartment thought it was hers
probably is true but the fact that she
killed someone the fact that an innocent
man is dead and even if you didn't do it
on purpose you you still have to pay the
price for that that's what I would think
usually would be manslaughter but in any
case so she's going to prison
Joshua Brown is a man who lived in the
same apartment complex he testified
against Geiger at the the trial and his
testimony is part of what sent her to
jail although I would imagine that even
without his testimony she'd probably
still be going to jail because the fact
is there's there's no denying it she
didn't even deny she did walk in in this
guy's apartment and kill him so in some
ways I you know it's it's even without
the testimony you think he probably
still she's probably still going to jail
but then it just so happens that after
the trial after the conviction a few
days later Brown ended up dead in what
police say is a botched drug deal now
botched drug deals happen all the time
there's nothing nothing unusual about
that people are killed in BOTS drug
deals unfortunately all the time nothing
unusual about that either the only
unusual thing is that coincidentally
this guy had just testified against a
police officer in a high-profile case
that's what made it unusual
so the conspiracy theories start with a
lot of people on the internet and even
some people in the media speculating
that he was killed by police
because he was a witness and now they're
they're coming up with this story to
cover it up some people are being coy
about it saying well I don't know what
happened but the official story seems to
be a little fishy I don't know and then
you have for example stuff like this
this article in The Root titled
nobody is buying ballot Dallas PD's BS
story about Joshua Browns death and then
the article basically comes out and just
flat-out accuses the Dallas Police
Department of killing Joshua Brown the
article says when news broke that Brown
was gunned down in the parking lot of
his apartment complex as he exited his
vehicle many speculated that he had been
snuffed out by the police or by the
order of police he did after all testify
against a cop and participated in the
trial that ultimately sent her to prison
and then it goes on to essentially
endorse that view this is just a perfect
example as I said of how conspiracy
theories work there is no evidence at
all none
that police killed this man no evidence
what you have here is a coincidence
a guy testified he was in the news for
that and now he's dead that's a
coincidence
now just because a coincident a
coincidence has happened that doesn't
mean that you get to concoct this whole
story around it you know and never mind
the story makes no sense
Brown already testified Geiger is
already convicted so if you're if you're
gonna kill a guy to stop him from
testifying you'd probably do it before
he testifies and before the person has
already been convicted I would think you
know if you're gonna testify against the
mob in in some trial they're gonna kill
you beforehand so that you don't testify
once you've already testified and the
testimony is out there it's it's a done
deal it's over now so then maybe you say
well it could have been vengeance maybe
it was it was it was revenge against
this guy which again even though that
makes no sense it already it there's no
evidence there's no reason to speculate
that that is just a story you came up
with in your head that's all that's all
that is but the story also doesn't make
sense because again if the Dallas PD if
there is this murderous cabal within the
Dallas Police Department and they are
willing to and capable of murdering a
guy and covering it up like like is
being alleged here then again they would
have done it before he testified they
would have waited until afterwards
that's not how these things work the the
fact that this man was able to get up
there and give his testimony unmolested
then that's pretty good at indication
that there isn't any murderers
conspiracy going on to kill off the
witnesses
and and besides why would they even do
that
Geiger killed an innocent man nobody
disputes the fact that she did she
doesn't even dispute it the Dallas
Police Department they weren't coming
out and and you know going out of their
way to defend her what why do they care
if she goes to jail you think they
really care if anything they probably
hate her more than everyone else does
because on top of the fact that she
killed a guy she also brought all this
bad PR to the Dallas the police barn so
it doesn't even make any sense on that
level it's just it's utterly completely
totally ridiculous but this is how
conspiracy theories work where you don't
need evidence you don't even need a
story that makes sense because we don't
have either of those things in this case
all you need is a coincidence
and that's how that's where most
conspiracy theories come from you need
some kind of you need two events to sort
of coincide that will allow you to come
in and construct an entire mythology
around it that's all you need or you
don't even need a coincidence you just
need something somewhat unusual you need
an unusual thing to occur and then
that's and then you're off to the races
because you can go in and make up your
story it's of course in a totally
illogical illegitimate way to operate
but this is what people do and it's not
exclusive to the right it's not
exclusive to the left this is just a
human there's something in human nature
it's a flaw that we all have where we
tend to do this all right
um let's go to emails Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
this is from Ben says hi Matt I don't
know I don't know enough people in my
daily life who have seen the Joker movie
so I've decided to take my opinions to
email in the hopes that someone else
will either agree with me or tell me how
wrong I am about my perspective this
will be a slight spoiler but you can
read ahead and decide if you think
there's enough to actually constitute a
spoiler in here however I'll try to be
vague one of the things that struck me
so spoiler alert okay
one of the things that struck me while
watching the movie and most of why I
believe the left-leaning media have
tried to get get out ahead of the film
with their scathing reviews is that the
villains in the movie are clearly
leftist the character of the Joker
himself is not political he says as much
himself but as followers the people who
are inspired by him are overtly leftist
they carried signs that said resist and
wealthy equals fascist and watching the
movie it was almost impossible to for me
to ignore the connection to groups like
an Tifa and those who provide them cover
in the media it's easy to think the
movie inspires violence when you
actually agree with many of the things
the villains and movie are fighting for
if you think wealthy people are fascists
and you regularly cover for groups like
an Tifa then of course the Joker and
those who support them seem like the
protagonists on the other hand if you
watch the movie with a clear moral lens
you can see the vote that the violence
is depicted tragically not celebrated
okay so that's it I've heard this point
before that so that's an interesting
take on why the media was so against
this movie and still is I guess what
you're saying is for those of us who are
not antifa apologists it's easy for us
to watch this and tell that this is this
violence is not being condoned or
promoted these are the bad guys
obviously but if you naturally
sympathize with that side of things then
to you it's gonna seem like
encouragement so yeah I guess there
might there might be something through
that although I still I I tend to think
that the media's narrative about the
Joker and their obsession with it was
also somewhat random it just kind of
naturally developed at first where they
came up with this narrative and it was
getting a lot of clicks and so they just
ran with it I think that's the main
thing
Joker was a movie a lot of people were
interested in a cultural pop culture
phenomenon and the media came up with a
narrative that was getting the clicks
and and they went with it I think that's
probably the main explanation this is
from QB says hi Matt on Twitter you said
the newest Walsh has finally joined us
in when my daughter was born I believe
that that premises matter a lot
when it comes to politics obviously the
premise I have a problem with is the
premise that babies are only valuable
after birth your dog daughter already
was already with you before birth so I
wanted to ask if pro-life people should
stop using this kind of language and
like I do refuse to celebrate birthdays
I think all of this glamorizing of birth
only feeds into the devaluing of preborn
babies what do you think there's a logic
to your point I've heard this from other
people
I think we're fusing to celebrate
birthdays probably takes it further than
you need to I think well you call the
glamorizing of birth I think that only
tends to highlight to underline the
significance of human life and how
beautiful to talk to talk about how how
amazing and miraculous and beautiful the
birth of a new child is I think that
helps the pro-life cause I don't think
it undermines it at all however you're
right when we you know with the way we
the ways we don't we talk about a new
child or even even what I did I'm a lot
of us do this when I when my wife was
pregnant I would say something like I've
got three kids and another on the way
when really no I've got four kids it's
just one happens to be located inside my
wife's womb at the moment and and I
think you're right and I I became more
now obviously when I say that and when I
knew pro-lifer says it we don't mean it
literally we do obviously recognize that
our child exists now and is a person is
a human and all of that it's just a it's
just a kind of a figure of speech
it's a colloquialism but with this
pregnancy i did become more aware of
that because i think you're right that
we should be careful with our language
we don't have to be hypersensitive about
it but the language does does matter
especially when it comes to something
like abortion because for the left their
entire position revolves around depends
on the manipulation of language which
makes it important for us to be
cognizant of that which I guess I I
tried to be
this pregnancy I probably was I
obviously didn't quite totally succeed
all right let's go to Christine says hi
Matt have you ever heard of the trolley
problem here's how Wikipedia summarizes
the dilemma you see a runt a runaway
trolley moving toward five tied up or
otherwise incapacitated people lying on
the main track you are standing next to
a lever that controls a switch if you
pull the lever the trolley will be
redirected onto a sidetrack and the five
people on the main track will be saved
however there is a single person lying
on the side track you have two options
one do nothing and allow the trolley to
kill the five people on the main track
to pull the lever diverting the trolley
onto the side track where it will kill
one person which is the more ethical
option or more simply what is the right
thing to do so Matt what say you first
of all thank you for this email I love I
love these hypothetical moral dilemmas I
find them very fun to talk about and I
have heard of the trolley problem before
I think yeah this one's kind of an easy
one I think and I think most people
intuitively just kind of get it and
first of all the so at the end of the of
this hypothetical there's there's the
question which is the more ethical
option or more simply what is the right
thing to do I think those two questions
conflate that so that's not a legitimate
conflation there because those are
actually two separate questions
and the real question the right question
is what is the more ethical option
because that's for the second question
what's the right thing to do I think
that that insinuates that one of the
options is the wrong thing to do would
be morally wrong and I think in a
situation like this whether you pull the
lever or you don't in either case I
don't think you've committed a moral
wrong but I do think that there's a more
ethically there's a there's a there is a
better ethical option and that would be
to pull the lever and this is where the
principle of double effect comes in and
the principle of double effect says that
you can commit a
positive action which is meant to bring
about a positive result even if you know
that there is a likely side effect of
that action which will be negative so in
this case you pull the lever that's a
positive action you're trying to save
the five people and that is the the the
intended effect is to save the five
people unfortunately the side effect is
that probably that want the other guy on
the other track is a goner
that wasn't your intention that wasn't
that's not the the direct result you're
going for you're not intending to kill
the person but that is probably going to
be one of the things that happens as a
result of the action but it's okay it's
okay so that that's that's the principle
of double effect now it's not the same
thing as ends justify the means so in
fact I was reading a book recently that
talks about the trolley problem I can't
remember the book but they in a book the
author poses a wrinkle says okay now now
imagine that let's say you know same
situation trolleys coming down five
people on one track one on the other or
even let's say forget about the other
tractor trolleys coming down you got
five people on the track there's nowhere
else for the trolley to go there's no
lever you're standing up on like a
bridge or something watching this
happening you don't have a leather tube
lever to pull but you do have a very fat
man standing next to you on the bridge
so would it be okay to to shove them at
the fat man onto the track to stop the
the the trolley which would kill the fat
man but save the five people now I think
we all recognize that in that case no
you can't shove the guy onto the track
and we we all kind of intuitively
recognize that though when you think
about it it is a very fine distinction
because whether you're pulling lever
where let's say the fat man's tied on
the on the other track and you pull the
lever and he dies what really is the
difference between pulling a lever and
sending the Train in his direction or
just of throwing him on the track to
begin with well the distinction is you
know one is principle of double effect
and one is end
justified means because in one case you
are directly killing this guy by
throwing him on the track and the side
effect of that evil action of killing
someone is that you save five other
people that is ends justify the means
and that doesn't work so I hope I
answered your question I think that's
that's the answer but there isn't
another interesting thing here which is
we all as I said intuitively recognize
most of us I think would answer this
question in the same way and we would
say yeah you can pull the lever but no
obviously you can't throw somebody on
the track to save the 5 we all
intuitively recognize that even if we
can't exactly explain why we would say
most of us would say yeah of course you
can't throw the fat guy but yeah you can
pull the lever I think a lot of us
probably can't exceed even if we don't
know the phrase principle of double
effect and justify the means even we
can't go into detail explaining it we
all just instinctively recognize and we
can sort through what is really a
complicated ethical dilemma and we could
just do it automatically which is a
really interesting thing and I and I
think that fact poses a serious problem
for people who try to explain human
morality on strictly evolutionary terms
because it's not just that we have as
some people would claim evolved the
ability for moral reasoning it's not
just that it is that we have this
capacity it's not even really reasoning
we have this capacity to automatically
recognize intuitively within ourselves
the correct moral action without even
working it out in our heads I think that
is very difficult to explain on
evolutionary terms but anyway that's not
what you what you asked so I'll stop
rambling thanks for the question thanks
everybody for watching and listening
Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you